(tense music)
(groaning)
- Like you said, I'm not a killer,
but this is about her.
- I'm telling you.
- I'm scared.
I'm very scared of what
you would do to her.
Maple almond latte?
Two Stevia.
Two tablespoons of peanut oil.
Could've gone either way.
He's lied about so many things.
Who knew, the peanut allergy was real.
(eerie music)
I guess Benji's gonna die an honest man.
(gunshot)
(tense music)
- Paco, come here, I wanna talk to you.
Paco, come here, I'm not gonna hurt you.
- Paco?
- Paco, get over here I wanna talk to you.
Paco, come out here.
You're dead.
- Hey, Ron.
(choking)
- Joe!
- Paco.
(panicked breathing)
- You aint got it?
- Please don't, you don't have to do this.
You don't have to.
I'm nothing like you.
- I know you, you're from my party, right?
You're Forty's friend?
You were trying to help him,
you were trying to be a hero.
Is that what you think this is, huh?
You feel like you're a piece of shit
so you're trying to be a hero.
- That's enough.
- Ruining my life is not gonna
save you from your demons,
all right.
What we went through, this shit stays.
No amount of sex or drugs
or success or religion
or surviving fucking ball cancer,
that's not gonna save
you, okay, nothing can.
- He's trying to get in my head.
Love can.
We're nothing alike.
- Love is the biggest phony of them all.
You want something real?
An orgasm is real.
- He's desperate.
He's trying to win with words and ideas
that live up to nothing but the truth.
He is bad.
Someone needs to stop him and he knows it.
(tense music)
- Hey man, did you,
did you want a bump?
- [Joe] Yeah, yeah.
- [Elijah] Whoa, bro.
(Elijah screams)
- [Sandy] Stop!
You're hurting!
Get off of me!
- [Male] You're fucking lying!
- [Sandy] Stop!
- [Male] Tell me his fucking name!
- [Sandy] Get away from me!
Let go of me!
You crazy!
(gunshot)
- [Joe] What am I?
- What did you do?
What did you do?
You shouldn't have done that Joey.